ce qui n'est pas interdit est autorisé
en matière de travail et là je voudrais
faire prendre conscience tout le monde
que nous sommes très interdépendants
pour la santé et tous en soutien les
soignants qui sont au front au front de
cette guerre et que derrière à l'arrière
comme on dit en langage de guerre
il faut aussi que les activités contenus
les français ils ont besoin de produits
alimentaires de produits de nettoyage
ils ont besoin d'internet pour l'école à
la maison et pour le télétravail
ils ont besoin d'électricité ils ont
besoin de transport je vais pas faire la
longue liste mais quand vous regardez de
boutons vous il n'ya pas de métier
qu'ils soient inutiles à la nation il
n'est pas question de mettre en danger
la protection des salariés
la première priorité c'est de
sauvegarder l'emploi c'est pour ça que
nous faisons un plan de chômage partiel
parce massif comme on n'a jamais fait en
france c'est ainsi que nous rendrons à
la fois la vie quotidienne possible pour
les français
nous protégerons les salariés et que
nous saurons repartir avec les
compétences nécessaires demain quand la
crise sera terminée